what do you think about
uh el salvador becoming the first
country to approve um
a cryptocurrency bitcoin in this case as
uh as a legal currency
and where's this trend going first of
all this event
if you mention the bitcoin conference
the bitcoin folks believe that this is a
monumental event do you think this is a
start of something new
well they're both right the critics and
the the pro people
um so the critics are saying this is a
nothing burger and it's just a publicity
event
for el salvador and then the people said
this is the most monumental event they
may actually be right because there's
reciprocal agreements
when a country issues a currency other
countries honor that
usually and it trades on forex exchanges
so if like bitcoin
becomes a recognized currency of a
country then it may be the case that
the united states and the european union
others can't actually stop them from
trading on forex exchanges and
being treated as a currency from a
regulatory perspective so it's like a
really clever backdoor
into the the league of nations uh and
actually we had this crazy hairbrained
idea years ago we were down in mexico at
the satoshi round table and we're like
hey
let's go buy a country let's go let's go
to tuvalu and get them to do something
with the cryptocurrency
because they sell everything in tuvalu
like the tv extension and their fishing
rights and
taiwan pays them money to recognize them
and so forth
so i'm like man maybe we can convince
tavalu to do something with crypto
and that didn't work out so well but uh
but now el salvador is actually playing
the game and that's a real country it's
got like five million people
and so forth so we know the president's
brother and uh we've had some
conversations there so maybe we'll go
you know the next few months and see
what's going on there and do a state
visit and talk to the president
but it's a it's an interesting
development and it's one of those things
that it can't quite be ignored because
the nation states doing it
on the other hand you have to manage
expectations it's the central bank
taking a position in bitcoin
you know uh are they actually switching
over to a cryptocurrency as their unit
of account
um are they now getting off of bis and
they're all using the
the settlement rails of central banks
are they actually blockchaining the
entire country and they have some broad
ambitious agenda to go and do all that
that remains to be seen and so it really
is a commitment there the other thing is
that if you're
autocratic these systems are not so good
for you
because the minute you adopt these types
of systems you're pushing a lot of power
to the edges
so there's a world of difference between
optics and actual commitment
an actual commitment is i'm prepared to
accept the consequences that
the state is going to lose a lot of
power along the way
and the problem is it's not clear to me
some of these politicians who are
pro-blockchain
and i'm not making a statement on el
salvador in particular i'm just saying
in general
are fully aware of that reality a lot of
them seem to think that somehow they can
contain the blockchain genie in the
bottle and blockchain their whole
country but
you know stay president for life that
doesn't work
once they have that power they're gone
you